welcome to CBS this morning and that's
where we began Democrats democratic
candidates unloaded on each other last
night CBS News presidential debate in
Charleston South Carolina
the national front-runner senator Bernie
Sanders was repeatedly attacked over his
ideas his record and his electability he
argued his campaign has momentum and a
grassroots movement behind it that can
lead Democrats to victory in a CBS News
poll after the debate nearly half of
viewers we spoke to said they were
nervous about the candidates almost the
same amount said they were optimistic at
o'keefe in North Charleston covered
laughs the last debate before Saturday
South Carolina's primary and Super
Tuesday next week and is this gonna
shake up the race at all the way think
sure could Anthony good morning we're
outside a civil-rights breakfast here at
a North Charleston Church former Vice
President Joe Biden is trying to
maintain his slim lead over senator
Sanders so he went on the attack a bit
last night
but he wasn't the only one trying to
land some final blows okay often talking
over each other I think she was talking
about my plan not yours I think we were
talking about math and it doesn't take
two hours to do the math the candidates
made their final arguments before the
South Carolina primary and Super Tuesday
I win South Carolina from the first
sentence he uttered senator Bernie
Sanders went after former New York Mayor
Michael Bloomberg the economy is doing
really great for people like mr.
Bloomberg and other billionaires but it
was Sanders who was the punching bag for
most of the attacks Bernie and I agree
on a lot of things but I think I would
make a better president than Bernie I
like Bernie we came in together to the
Senate but I do not think that this is
the best person to lead the ticket I'm
hearing my name mentioned a little bit
tonight and Sanders was pressed on his
recent comments to 60 minutes about
Fidel Castro I have opposed
authoritarianism all over the world what
I said is what Barack Obama said in
terms of Cuba that Cuba made progress on
education not gonna win these critical
critical House and Senate races if
people in those races have to explain
why the nominee of the Democratic Party
is telling people to look at the bright
side of the Castro regime Bloomberg who
will be on the ballot for the first time
next week also faced his own attacks and
the fact that he cannot earn the trust
of the core of the Democratic Party
means he is the riskiest candidate
standing on this side Senate have the
experience I have the resources and I
have the record and all of the sideshows
that the senator wants to bring up have
nothing to do with that and in a state
where nearly 60 percent of Democratic
voters are African American issues of
race we're center stage and the only
person on this stage who believes in
reparations for slavery my entire life
I've been involved in the black
community we can no longer pretend that
everything is race neutral I'm conscious
of the fact that there's seven white
people on this stage talking about
racial justice the candidates also
waiting on what they would do to stop
the spread of the corona virus the
president fired the pandemic specialists
in this country two years ago so there's
nobody here to figure out what the hell
we should be doing I would better
coordinate throughout my presidency to
be ready for the next pandemic and to
prepare for this one I would be on the
phone with China and making it clear we
are going to need to be in your country
you have to be open you have to be clear
we have to know what's going on we have
to be there with you and insist on it
and consistent system system in our CBS
News poll of debate Watchers viewers
said they were most impressed by senator
Sanders followed by former Vice
President Biden and senator Warren the
campaigning continues across South
Carolina and Super Tuesday states today
this breakfast hosted by the Reverend Al
Sharpton candidates making appearances
across this state and the fourteen
others as the voting near Sun Saturday
and next Tuesday all right thank you
very much